okay let's follow up on what's going on
with the Ukraine story as I told you
yesterday every couple of hours we get
some additional confirmation or
admission that the entire Donald Trump
extortion of the Ukrainian president by
withholding hundreds of millions of
dollars in aid under the demand that
Ukraine smear Joe Biden is coming out as
reported from the beginning exactly
every few hours we learn another five
percent of the story is true now you
might remember yesterday we learned that
Donald Trump indeed withheld the aid and
in fact we found out that the decision
was made just a few days before Donald
Trump's july 2019 phone call with the
ukrainian president but you might also
recall that donald trump explained the
reason he didn't want to give ukraine
the money was because he didn't want to
give money to a corrupt country like he
supposedly discussed on the phone with
the ukrainian president that was
explanation number one donald trump has
now come up with a completely different
explanation which i guess we can call
explanation number two which is that the
reason he withheld the aid from ukraine
is he was mad at the european union for
not having contributed more money to
ukraine which is not even remotely
believable Donald Trump spoke to
reporters before heading to meetings at
the United Nations in New York City
which were an entirely separate gong
show that I will talk about with you a
little bit later on today and Donald
Trump said yeah I did withhold the
financial aid from Ukraine but it was
because he wants other countries in
Europe to be giving more money to
Ukraine not of course because he was
trying to strong-arm Ukraine into
investigating and subsequently smearing
Joe Biden let's take a look at the video
also note that Donald Trump says in the
same sentence that he gave them the
money but that he would withhold it
again which is an implicit confirmation
that he did withhold it which he
previously admitted to but now denies
and then immediately self contradicts if
my explanation is confusing if that
summary is confusing then you are
correctly understanding it it is
incredibly confusing take a look at this
so here's just a very simply we're
watching Venezuela very closely as far
as withholding funds those funds were
paid they were fully paid
my complaint has always been and I
withhold again and I'll continue to
withhold until such time as Europe and
other nations contribute to Ukraine
because they're not doing it just the
United States we're putting up the bulk
of the money and I'm asking why is that
and I want Europe and it's always been
this and everybody knows it every single
reporter knows that everybody in the
administration knows that what I want
and I insist on it is that Europe has to
put up money for Ukraine also why is it
only the United States putting up the
money so listen Trump's definitely
panicking here but this is also a
strategy sometimes known as the Gish
gallop sometimes known as the firehose
of falsehood and Rudy Giuliani has been
a big player in Donald Trump employing
this strategy you say something
different every day
Rudy is a pro at it Trump is pretty good
at it
you say one thing and then the next day
you say the opposite and what you're
counting on is people ultimately just
being too damn exhausted or confused to
really figure it out
combined with bamboozling your own
supporters into believing that you at
some point explained it even though
they're all contradictory explanations
and unfortunately it often works they're
actually doing something right here
which is that while everyone who cares
about the facts is busy trying to figure
out what happened Trump and Rudy and
everybody else are trying to get ahead
of it and shaping the narrative just
like the William Barr propaganda letter
was able to get out ahead of the Moller
report and obfuscate and completely
mislead with bars summary of molars
report then they use that bogus
propaganda letter as the reference
document that all the trumpets point to
and say we got the real story we got it
in William Bars letter even though that
letter was completely divorced from the
reality of what the molar report said
now as I mentioned to you yesterday the
real story here is the suppression of
the whistleblower report and that has
gone by the wayside and the discussion
is increasingly shaped by Donald Trump
about the reasons why he withheld the
aid and the content of that July 29
phone call with the Ukrainian president
what we really need is the whistleblower
complaint and the whistleblower to
testify under oath not some absurd phone
call transcript that Donald Trump now
says he is going to put out and that is
exactly what we want to talk about next
let's dig into the transcript